welcome back a local pro golfer is  taking a swing at fighting hunger here  in the valley  today lpga golfer danielle kang king  kang rather teamed up with happy foodie  to donate 65 thousand dollars worth of  meals  to food banks across the las vegas  valley we caught up early with the team  this morning as they prepared those  deliveries  being an athlete or whatever it may be  has given me a platform to  meet people and have the opportunity but  being able to put that in use and help a  lot of people is  pretty amazing to be honest the mass  meal distribution event was hosted by  three square food bank  in total king and happy foodie will  donate over 11  000 meals by the end of the day that is  fantastic great work